dude I saw pause the Tiger today and he
recognized me it's not name-dropping
it's what happened to me I'm friends
with pause the tiger now that's weird to
say but at the same time it's like why
shouldn't I be friends of the Tigers
mascot hey oh okay yeah you're mad
because I met pause the tiger why are
you being such a jerk because you're a
complete asshole to me in my dream last
night Kim just walked right by me like
you didn't even recognize me
Tim Tim you walk right by Mike I was
just so white guy also I was white in
the dream well that's why I didn't
recognize you you're white oh you saw
Paul I don't want to talk about my
friend pause now I want to hear about
this dream man oh what's it its pause oh
hello absolutely yeah can I bring a
friend no okay then no worries I'll go
by myself
you